what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
pretty epic but also kind of strange
weird news today about dr doom and a
doctor doom project currently being in
the works and if it's what we think it
is it's gonna be kind of weird and if
you've heard this news you know exactly
what i'm talking about although we are
going to dive into some other things
involving doctor doom today so stick
around i'll put some clarity on the
situation and if you haven't heard the
news it looks like they have cast dr
doom and doom could be played by howard
stern and if you don't know who that is
look him up real quick and you'll all of
a sudden think that wow this is very
interesting but howard stern has his own
show the howard stern show and during
one of the commercials one of the ad
breaks he accidentally left his mic on
where he was talking about how he is
playing doctor doom for marvel and how
he talked to robert downey jr so it
certainly sounds like a doom project is
in the works at marvel studios and that
is what we've actually been hearing
recently rumbles about doom being the
main villain and that makes sense
because the fantastic four are coming
and typically you don't have the
fantastic four without their main
villain dr doom however since the
fantastic four have been done before
marvel studios might switch it up just a
little bit and if they've truly cast
howard stern as doctor doom one it's an
incredibly interesting choice and two
i'd like to know what you think about
this so let me know right away right now
in the comments down below but let's
talk about a few options of what this
could actually mean and first let's
start off by playing the actual audio
that has howard stern saying all of this
that's what i did on america's got
talent
[Music]
so in case you couldn't hear that
perfectly clear because of course there
were ads playing over it because his
microphone was actually not supposed to
be on that's how this all got out here's
what he actually said they're going over
the schedule with me and it's going to
suck then somebody asks if he's going to
be working and he says i told you i'm
going to do dr doom that's the thing but
believe me i'm effing miserable about it
i called robert downey jr and was asking
him acting techniques do you have a
number for john and we assume this is
jon favreau but howard stern knows
everybody he could be talking about
literally any john so this is really
really interesting this is coming
directly from him and he is saying that
he's going to be doing dr doom now keep
in mind right here this is kind of a
crucial and very important part he says
he's going to do dr doom he doesn't
actually say that he's going to be
playing the role of dr doom he says he's
going to do doctor doom so that right
there means that he could be referring
to dr doom simply as the movie he could
be doing the movie he could be acting in
the movie not actually playing victor
von doom himself because i gotta tell
you although i have nothing against
howard stern at all i don't think he'd
make a really good doctor doom plus not
to mention he doesn't really act it's
not like he's an actor he is a host he
hosts his show he was on america's got
talent as one of the judges which of
course is somewhat acting but he doesn't
have any you know main acting jobs under
his belt or any major huge roles under
his belt as well which you would assume
with marvel studios whoever they would
cast as dr doom would have some major
acting experience behind them even if
it's small roles and it's a relatively
unknown actor you can assume that that
actor has a lot of experience still so
this may mean that he's simply involved
in the project but not playing doctor
doom but let's talk about the options
like i mentioned one is that he actually
could be playing doctor doom of course
that is an option based off of what he
has said he even says that he called
robert downey jr to talk about acting
techniques but that right there is kind
of a sign to me that he's not going to
be playing the main victor von doom
again he doesn't have that much acting
experience and if you have to call
somebody else to talk about acting
techniques you're not getting cast as a
main role for marvel studios you're just
not now a smaller role sure there's
absolutely a possibility that he's going
to be in this dr doom project which i
believe is what's happening here so
that's our second option he is simply
playing another character and this
character could be a small character it
could be a character who was there every
now and then maybe like a henchman of
doctor doom or an assistant for doctor
doom somebody who works for him but
basically not the main role and now i've
heard some people say well maybe he's
simply working on the film or the
project but not actually playing any
type of role in it well he does say he
calls robert downey jr and he asks him
about acting techniques so based off of
that right there i would definitely say
that he is playing in an acting role and
not simply just working on the movie now
another thing that could be happening
here that i haven't really heard a lot
of people mention is that he could be
doing a different doom project that is
not taking place inside of the mcu we
know that marvel has podcasts they have
the wolverine podcast which is really
good if you haven't heard that i suggest
you check it out and they have others as
well so this very well could be for a
podcast it also could be for some type
of different show it could be for an
animated show we know that marvel
studios is doing what if too it very
well could be for that we know that
they're doing another spider-man
animated show and x-men animated show he
could be voicing dr doom in any of these
shows and that could be what he is
referring to when he says i'm doing dr
doom now as far as my take is concerned
i actually do think he is talking about
an mcu dr doom project but i do not
believe he is playing doom the reason
that i think it is an mcu project is
because he does talk about talking to
robert downey jr he says he called
robert downey jr iron man and then he
was asking for john's number and i do
assume that it's john favreau who has
just been a huge staple to the mcu it's
a star wars and lucasfilm but we're
talking about marvel right now so again
i don't think that howard stern would be
cast as dr doom if you think about it it
just really doesn't make that much sense
one he doesn't have the acting
experience for it and marvel studios
isn't going to bring in actors who
aren't really actors don't get me wrong
like i said howard stern is great at
what he does but he's not an actor he's
a host so that doesn't make too much
sense one is that he doesn't really have
the build or look for victor von doom
and i mean this in no offense to him but
he's too old for the role this is like
talking about hugh jackman coming back
to play wolverine well he's too old for
the role right now and i think most
people would agree that howard stern
just is kind of too old for the role we
need a doctor doom who's going to be in
the mcu for 10 years maybe even longer
hopefully everything is going to
eventually lead up to god emperor doom
one of the greatest comic book villains
of all time and especially if this is
going to be leading up to avengers
secret wars so what i believe has
happened here is that howard stern has
simply confirmed that a doom project is
in the works i do not think he is
playing doctor doom but what this has
shown us is that doctor doom is coming
to the mcu which is fantastic and has
actually been rumored for some time now
a lot of the insiders have been posting
tweets talking about doctor doom and
they've said that he's coming sooner
than we think and this right here just
proves that they were right it looks
like a doctor doom project is in the
works and they've already cast for it
which is the crazy part because if
they've cast howard stern in some other
role they've probably cast victor von
doom which means the mcu has their
doctor doom who do you think it could be
who do you think would make a good
doctor doom there are a lot of good
casting choices out there and like i
always say in feige we trust he's always
cast very well for these roles i'm not
really worried about who they cast but i
am excited to find out but hit me with
your best guess down below let me know
who you would like to see play doctor
doom don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
me